it's good to see boards look preaches
one thing okay but this dude is blind
and the other dude can't even walk come
on man the only thing that can explain
it it's 94 feet of blacktop what are you
talking about okay you sound insane all
right
those dudes will get us killed on a
court about a decade or so ago I want to
see James Brown I got to meet him
beforehand and his dressing room Oh mr.
Brown was in a wheelchair looked like he
could barely walk but a funny thing
happened they rolled him on the side of
that stage he came to life it turns out
being on that stage it was like oxygen
to him he stood up out of that chair
indeed work and that's the same way that
cord up a trucker's gonna be like oxygen
to death it's a young blood you don't
stop playing because you'll be too old
you get old because you stop playing
look drew that was a great story and
everything but I leave me to see don't
play man can I see him play ain't no
time for crewing something that don't
need to be proved so what should we do
then
see your team clocks a-ticking
[Music]